yeah welcome to this video playing
nefertum here in the five-minute pool on
icc so let's see King zinnia with our
Kim let's go with age 39 so this line is
Sam okay please please ephi that's
interesting not going for any of any Ben
only type of setup in the first place so
let's see what is doing it's mostly
playing in Sims as they tend to do okay
well I have Queen d2 year and age 6 what
are you doing he's just giving away that
corn okay but what kind of what approach
is that I don't I don't get it sometimes
you just deport down for nothing and
basically lost seven spent 17 seconds
okay of course you can try to to do some
kind of Hail Mary sacrifice and hope
it's working yeah and let's chat
sometimes those are those things do work
so let's see I'm going here tending
Bishop g4 to see see see may be able to
go f3 here and even sacrifice I ok
Knight takes Knight takes bishop takes
rook f3 no yeah that's it inlets maybe
check
King age to hear so playing Queen age
for probably look each one hmm doesn't
have a great discover check at least I
don't see it I can take everyone of
course take-take-take yeah that's that's
um and somewhat dangerous so let's see I
probably need my night to defend this it
is really dangerous as weird as it is
last night on a sixth and so on so not
playing with any kind of pieces but and
then maybe night h2 was there was a bad
idea thinking about it maybe that was a
bad idea just going over with the King
immediately maybe that would have been
better it's very very likely so let's
see how to play from here maybe here
King II to Queen is three row gauge 1
i'm still a pawn up so it's um it's not
that bad just that double porn doesn't
inspire much optimism but okay I can
probe probably and get it probably get a
4 in somewhat later so look h1
so we how to how to get have to get the
night to eat too that would be very
helpful look age three King back 92 or
something Jerry it takes them a while to
get that night into the game maybe you
will play b5 that would be very typical
of those kind of player 2 / out wouldn't
help at all play be three but would be
very typical yep doesn't do much hopes
that I take on b5 but of course I don't
now the B file is opened for me actually
let's see where the night wants to go to
eat to really that would be would be
nice to get in but not so easy waiting
with the queen is also an idea I don't
get to g2 what is he doing he moves the
Queen a place Knight f6 then possibly to
age five on a very good day hmm well I
can't play can we can play that actually
I'm so slow with tactics look at 39 h5
he cannot take that in the first place
and then 92 next that took me ages
question is I could have gone to d2
maybe that would have been better
anyway that's not bad at all so 92 is
playing Queen age for huh yeah anyway I
want to do want to get rid of that
situation here yes to play to gauge for
that's no bigger alternative and now
f-4s get this in
okay 96 really can allow that that seems
optimistic check so I can take the age
but it's probably not really great
keeping the Queen's on should be better
really so yes one check here that's
really all of it so I can even put the
Queen here which will bind his pieces
King have to a king g2g 3f for this kind
of thing out Zach king v3 should be okay
can check on e5 but I can click winner
form check for Queen c3 is not so clear
as king g4s answered by Knight f6 but I
can do this threatening Queen f8 as well
that should trade Queens actually check
so if I ever if five years my night is
dominating is not completely interesting
moment down fatigue with with the King
96 this is it better to play night c5
here maybe and it's probably bit better
check and then nighty for next and then
push the two connected pawns
time warning so Becky then see 5 black
resins and not deplete that badly I mean
this pawn sacrifice is just it's just
nothing I just pawn down but i think i
think probably that was a wrong wrong
approach that that night h2 stuff it
really is wrong I played that too
quickly this is a typical reaction
sometimes when you think the opponent
plays total nonsense so you play a quick
move basically saying I can do whatever
you want it's nonsense but that's what's
wrong as I should have thought a bit
about this because night eh to really
gives them lots of opportunities that
are totally unnecessary to give so I
should probably rethink this for example
I could have played something like this
here yeah and then just run the King to
eat too that's much better for example
if your ends easy to see it you just
have to take a moment to to to to look
at it and this is just no compensation
whatsoever or this is also better if you
do it like this you're over protect f3
much much better so yeah that's a bad
move simply he could have played this
immediately did he do that no played
Nagi five and now i have f 3 which is
probably better but he could have played
that immediately and this is already a
huge problem here in IGN so on that's
winning for black and that h2 was so
terrible now I have to go f3 and still
he has this opportunity Chad yeah that's
a funny funny development here yeah I
immediately returned the exchange the
computer wants to play rook c1 and says
white wins but who at something where I
mean I'm a natural optimist but I'm kind
of scared here
this yeah computer says nothing is going
on
yeah the computer doesn't doesn't find
anything even that is somewhat deeper
depth so there's probably no made it
gives life plus one point something but
okay I didn't trust that I wanted to
have some clarity in the position so
returning the the exchange is a good
idea and what is much better here still
it's it's the pawn still I get an F for
possibly and the night on 86 is not
playing unfortunately it took me ages to
see that move which is stronger than the
other regrouping queen bee three is
actually a good move to pick a computer
move and then here because this is not
really a threat yeah that's true but
okay I wanted to the other said b5 is
probably not a great idea okay but
behalf okay before I it's very strong
again pointed out by the engine okay but
I didn't want that I mean it didn't look
for anything like that I was glad that I
got that regrouping in and run rid of
that pawn that rook and got f1 and here
this is a technical way to do it check
and the very safe way I mean here why
just wins without any particular problem
by technical means okay well thanks for
watching